I wish I say it to Rob all the time I
wish we could just do one week of
filming right now like right now right
because of just
like
my awareness of like the world and what
that was and what we were part of and
like who I just wish I could experience
it like one episode give me one episode
right now like just drop me back in for
a couple what would the episode be
about good question um the family some
sort of internal struggle with the
family so a family heavy one um I always
loved moments when Meadow and Tony got
quiet together and it was all our scenes
when we would get quiet together the
dialogue would actually be really
limited it would just be these like
heavy like pregnant pauses and he Jim
was the type of scene partner where it
felt like he was there and his only
intention was to make me as good as I
could be wow and it had nothing to do
with him every time I work with him I
felt like his sole purpose was I'm going
to make you I'm going to help you give
your best [__] take Jamie yeah did
you feel the same way like I'm Jim Jim
I'm gonna make you as good as you can be
definitely didn't feel that way but I
more was like just watching a really
amazing that's when you know you it when
you're so confident in yourself as a as
a performer that you just want to make
the other person it had nothing to do
with his confidence cuz he was actually
not he wasn't he was insecure oh my God
yes what would he do like I doing
another take [__] what the [__] am I
what's the [__] line no he would
question himself like there would be
moments where he'd be like I [__]
suck but but I appreciated that because
I've had those thoughts but I didn't say
them out loud cuz I don't want anybody
to know that I think I suck he was
confident enough to say it out loud oh I
yeah yeah you know what I mean so yes I
guess there was a confidence there but
it was I think it came more from him
deeply caring deeply deeply caring he
was an exceptional human being i' I've
had that while I'm working like I'm
starting a scene and I just am like God
please cut please cut I want to say cut
right now I'm not going to because I
can't but this sucks and I'm not into it
and I well you better get into it cuz
you got another 3 minute scene here
going so okay [__] it and then you just
turn it on and then he like we could use
the last half of that I'm like that's
what I thought burn the first half burn
the [__] first half well I think
that's why I'm like would love to work
with you because I think that in TV it's
so fast-paced now that it's so hard to
like unless you're in a show for a
couple years to like get in a rhythm
with people and feel so safe with them
to be able to play like that like you
and I have a chemistry in a report in a
relationship where like if I work with
you I would feel so safe to do that and
I just when you're guest starring or
even like pilots and this it's so fast
it's so hard to be able to find that
just to jump into something and you
don't really know someone and it's a
little intimidating just it's just you
got the nerves you got this whole thing
but when you connect with someone that
you just look at and they're like hey
let's let's do this you want you want
and and they're just cool they want to
run it they want to play with you they
want to do that you know and just you
know I have I've had some of those um
relationships where they could say or I
could say because we were close enough
where I'd look at him and I Go Again
love it you I just say it again because
I got it back and then Tom would do the
same with me or whatever but you have to
be have if you don't know the person you
go do that again they're like what the
[__] [__] you what the [__] you telling
me but if you know the personone did
that you're like hey man you know
because we're in the moments and stuff
and if you see me and you're like hey
you know [__] just don't throw I th I
like curveballs I like people playing
with me let me do hey let me say that
line again take it back just take it
back to your line real quick and then
I'm gonna say three in a row like that
what the [__] are you doing what the
[__] are you
doing love it and you know what I mean
and you don't and and it's not some
people like no no I want to just go
right through the you know yes it's just
getting the moments getting the moments
and and not um and just trusting that's
nice it's nice to have a partner like
that cuz you don't always get that no
everyone wants to prove themselves I'm a
great actor I'm I'm okay I just I don't
care how great you think you are I want
to get a great performance so it's on
that camera and it could last a lifetime
and you really like look you can't
always care that much but right right
you try sometimes but get what you
need yeah I'm done go ahead deep that
was really I I'm aware uh I forgot what
I was going to say oh like you know you
can't always care about the story you're
at least I haven't always like cared
about the story that I'm telling and
sometimes when you're in it you don't
think about the story that you're
telling
but I would like I think the dream right
is to get to a point where you're you
feel passionate about the stories you're
telling yeah